- Now, you're tiny and
weak and I'm the opposite.
So, the objective of this
exercise is to get past me.
Now, a good idea might be
to cause a distraction.
Because otherwise, there'd
zero chance of you--
Blueberry!
Blueberry.
- That's some cold blooded (beep).
(laughing)
- That was Dave Bautista and Chloe Coleman
in their new movie, "My Spy".
So Chloe, someone told me that Dave got
a little too intense on set.
That you know, there might
have been a swear jar.
- Oh, you know, actually he
was swearing earlier backstage
and I have--
- I gave you 20 bucks backstage.
- Yeah, I have 20 bucks right here.
He gave me 20 bucks
because he was swearing.
- Oh my gosh.
How much Dave, do you
think that you contributed
to that jar?
(laughing)
- It got to the point
where I was just like,
I was paying her so much even on credit--
- Before you opened your mouth.
- Yeah.
- I don't know, maybe half of it.
Maybe half.
- Yeah.
- Maybe not, 100 bucks or so.
- 100 bucks?
You get it girl.
- It was like $2 a cuss word then.
Now it's like five bucks a--
- Yeah, five bucks a cuss word.
- See, I tell my kids,
you can curse like mommy,
when you pay your bills like mommy.
So yeah, you can say whatever you like
as soon as you start paying.
- And we were actually, yeah we were all,
I mean we're okay with it because we knew,
we were all aware that
there was children on set
we needed to be better by.
It was just something that I
guess once you're in a rhythm
of speaking a certain
way throughout your life.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's hard to contain and control.
- Hard to keep it classy.
- It is.
- [Chloe] I can understand.
- We made an effort.
- That's amazing.
- She donated all the money.
- Oh, you did?
- I donated it to the Amazon Rainforest
because you know when it set on fire
it was like yeah.
(audience clapping)
- That's amazing.
- Thank you.
We raised $256.
That's how many people
were swearing on set.
(laughing)
I was just, I was like are
they really gonna be this mad
about it, like how hard is it?
- It is so hard.
(laughing)